[Music]
[Music]
today's Massachusetts Institute of
Technology is a world-class Center for
teaching and research faculty students
and researchers are united in their goal
to advance the frontiers of knowledge
solve contemporary real world problems
following the vision laid out for MIT
150 years ago but the place itself has
certainly evolved and flourished since
those early days
it's hard to imagine how much the
scientific landscape has changed from
when founder William Barton Rogers first
started thinking about a new kind of
Polytechnic Institute
[Music]
we Barton Rogers was born at the
beginning of the 19th century and that
marks the beginning of an extraordinary
time in US history
it's really the transition that we're
gonna witness over a century from an
agrarian rural country into an urban and
industrial country we're beginning to
see the emergence of large cities
factories railroads canals all the early
instruments of big-time industry in the
United States there's surveying involved
there's mechanical engineering
there's geology there's all kinds of
civil engineering a sense of possibility
of what this new technology would mean
for the country was very much a Rogers
mind William Barton Rogers had a
lifelong interest in education and by
1835 he's a professor at the University
of Virginia
he soon signs on to lead a Geological
Survey for the state though he loves the
project he has a big problem finding
qualified workers Rogers inability to
hire workers for his survey that
combines scientific knowledge and the
ability to use technical apparatus was a
great problem to his way of thinking he
wasn't the only person that needed an
individual with that skill the world was
filled with new industries and they all
needed people that combined smarts and
skill eventually Rogers decides to leave
behind the frustrations and political
turmoil he's encountered in Virginia's
slave society and move north to the
vibrant city of Boston Boston was one of
the leading commercial centers of the
country and the area surrounding Boston
was without question the most developed
industrially of any state in the Union
there probably was not an American city
that had more of a need for engineers
than Boston the city itself was being
transformed
one of the greatest engineering projects
of the 19th century filling in of the
Back Bay and then you had these reform
movements temperance movements pacifist
movements and of course the famous
anti-slavery abolitionist movement was
this was the place
Boston was so radical and it's reformed
spirit the wealth generated by all of
this industry Bostonians put into
various philanthropic enterprises in
Downton schools hospitals libraries
museums various institutions which
benefit the broader community Rodgers
writes in his memoirs how much he likes
the so called enterprising spirit and
even uses the word knowledge seeking
spirit of this area for decades Rodgers
had been talking with his brother Henry
about a new kind of Polytechnic
institution at the time the ideals of
science really focused on fundamental
principles somewhat disconnected from
the real problems of industry and the
people who worked in industry they began
thinking about how to incorporate
science into what they referred to as
the useful arts today we would call that
technical technology it's a
revolutionary idea that someone will go
to school to get training to become an
architect an engineer a scientist these
are typically occupations that people
would learn by doing this was
experimental from the get-go even the
word technology was new at that time he
wanted students who had a grasp of human
nature of basic sciences of mathematics
far beyond the requirements for making
this with that machine work he wanted to
train students who would be able to kind
of guide the nation through
industrialization not just bill through
the widgets
different players are coming together
trying to bring a bunch of different
scientific and practical institutions
together and Rodgers proves very skilled
at taking that set of people and
orienting their ideas toward his
proposal they knew it was going to be in
Boston and the land in Back Bay was the
place to put it so they were going to
have to convince the Massachusetts State
Legislature that not only was the school
worth establishing but that it was worth
designating a piece of land for the
proposal was bought to the state of
Massachusetts and the first step is to
essentially incorporate it as a state
corporation and that's what we celebrate
on the founding day of April 10 to 1861
when the governor finally signs the MIT
Charter
[Music]
[Music]
just two days after mi t--'s founding on
April 10th in 1861 the first shots are
fired on Fort Sumter in South Carolina
and with the start of the Civil War it
meant that classes at MIT could not
start right away
this proved fortuitous for MIT because
it allowed them the opportunity to raise
additional funds to acquire the land to
start construction to hire faculty one
can imagine that when Rogers tried to
raise money its wartime and energies are
being devoted to other things yet on the
other hand if we have optimism about the
outcome of the war we can see the
necessity for young men and women to
become engineers and scientists to be
able to solve these other problems when
the Morrill Act is passed in Washington
in 1862
it grants every state some land that
then they can either use or sell to
found an agricultural or mechanical
institution Rogers is colleagues one
support from the state legislature that
a portion of the funds from the land
grant act would be dedicated to this new
school assuming that they could raise
the other funds successfully and then
they had to go out house by house
factory to factory and convince people
one at a time to donate funds to support
this enterprise
[Music]
as the war is ending in 1865 the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
holds its first classes in rented space
in downtown Boston's mercantil building
while constructing its own buildings
near Copley Square Rogers vision for a
new kind of education with its emphasis
on hands-on learning made it crucial to
establish cutting-edge laboratories
Rogers had a very strong reaction
against light he considered rote
learning and so from the beginning MIT
was a great innovator in getting
laboratory work right down to the
earliest levels of the curriculum entry
undergraduate students would be entitled
to do a lot of work in the laboratories
with their own hands not just seeing
someone else demonstrate some effect
Rogers needed faculty who were going to
be willing to invent a new kind of
curriculum that they were going to have
to cobble together for the first time
ever laboratory exercises he allowed his
professors to basically experiment with
it tinker with it adjust it and build
the program I think of Pickering in
physics for example professor store who
was one of the early chemists at MIT and
both of them become very famous and
they're producing textbooks to accompany
the lab oriented educational process if
you look at the curriculum offered in
that very first set of classes at MIT in
1865 it looks a lot like what we call
the GI ARS today the general Institute
requirements that still every freshman
has to take mathematics chemistry
physics those are all required at MIT
from day one there was an emphasis on
combining kind of basic science with
applied things in the field students
took field trips to all kinds of sort of
working places where where the
technological world was being
and Barton Rogers wanted all that right
in the curriculum for his undergraduate
right from the start
[Music]
as a young startup MIT had its share of
hurdles ongoing money troubles takeover
attempts by neighboring Harvard but with
every passing year with every successful
student who went on to make his or her
mark in the world mi t--'s reputation
grew and the school standing became more
and more secure by 1894 President
Francis Amasa Walker was able to declare
in his annual report but the battle of
the new education is one proclaiming
that the influence of MIT and its
innovative ways are now recognized far
and wide in the early years the MIT way
of doing business with a great deal of
emphasis on hands-on and doing things in
reality contrasted very substantially
with the more classically oriented
education but today even for those
institutions which are more classically
oriented liberal arts they have moved
actually towards you know MIT
by the time operations moved across the
Charles to the brand-new Cambridge
campus in 1916 MIT s ongoing futures
seemed assured over the decades the
roadmap Rogers laid out for his school
has proved flexible enough to stay true
to his founding ideals while
incorporating new fields as they emerge
there have been a lot of continuities in
the history of MIT especially around the
type of curriculum that students are
required to follow there's surely a
greater range of choice today but the
emphasis on combining science with
practice is still an important dimension
of what is happening around the
Institute today that idea of mind and
hands meant upon us that goes right back
to the beginnings of MIT and it's
coincident with the idea that that the
learning takes place by doing so just by
see MIT today shows remarkable
commitment to the original vision
articulated by William Barton Rogers of
a place that solves great problems that
educate students who have the capacity
to be independent in their thinking
those commitments are timeless and
stretch across 150 years
[Music]
[Music]
you